les français veulent à nouveau un bis
repetita
c'était livre non mais revivent macron
le pen dont dont même les vols agnès vol
qui valent pas le prix vers le bas ne
l'aura pas en sa victoire qu'il va le
battre alors oui manuellement je suis et
avec valérie pécresse qui peut l'être et
rebecca c'est pour ça que moi ce que je
ne veux pas ce qui est de dispersion des
voix de la droite goyer et eric eric
zemmour est mon ami je le dis et je le
réaffirme ici sauf que ce qu'il propose
sont pas des bonnes solutions même sur
la question migratoire c'est pas une
bonne solution son ministère de la
rémunération je suis désolé ce qu'il
faut c'est un service public de la
reconduite au sein d'un ministère de
l'immigration parce que l'immigration
zéro
ça veut dire quoi se dire que là
aujourd'hui avec emmanuel macron la
france est ouverte à tous les vents et
là on aurait une france qui est fermée à
tout le monde est ce qu'on a envie de ça
non non donc moi je dis à tous ceux qui
se sentent de droite qui ont envie d'une
vraie politique ferme sur le régalien
efficace sur l'économie et qui
permettent une bonne gestion des deniers
publics c'est le programme porté par
valérie pécresse et par toute l'équipe
le nom alors moi
c'est un beau message nadine morano est
ce que vous pensez pas que un soutien de
nicolas sarkozy dans les prochains jours
pourraient avoir une petite impulsion
mali
mais vous savez aujourd'hui moi j'étais
très fier d'être ministre avec nadine de
nicolas sarkozy et il m'a beaucoup
appris mais aujourd'hui ce que je crois
c'est que les français ils veulent un ou
une présidente de la république et donc
ils veulent juste savoir ce que j'ai
dans mes tripes ce que j'ai dans le
coeur est et pourquoi je leur dis les
choses pourquoi je leur dis moi je sens
un certain nombre de soins et est ce que
je vais le faire et nadine l'a très bien
dit la différence entre macro et moi
elle est aussi pardon dans le
tempérament emmanuel macron c'est un
beau parleur ah ça c'est un beau parleur
j'en sais beaucoup beaucoup de belles
paroles qui la recherche c'est donc les
commerces mais on sait qu'elle cherchait
il va continuer mais qu'est ce qu'il a
fait au fond et est ce que la france va
mieux aujourd'hui qu'il ya cinq ans moi
ma région elle va mieux aujourd'hui que
avant que je suis